[Music]
on this Wednesday night Federal public
workers walk
[Applause]
what more than 100
000 civil servants are demanding we'll
stay out here for as long as they take
the impact on services and the pressure
on the prime minister
's patients try to escape a hospital
fire in Beijing the deadly consequences
Springtime in Saskatchewan the highway
closures and storm warnings thanks to
April snow
and a remarkable deep sea Discovery is
close to and a pilot and we are losing
it the scientists who found a pristine
new coral reef teaming with life
National with Donna freezing good
evening and thanks for joining us tens
of thousands of federal workers are off
the job today and on the picket line and
the longer the strike goes on the more
it will affect government services
across the country more than 155
thousand employees members of the public
service Alliance of Canada are on strike
though about 50 000 remain at work
because their jobs are essential picket
lines are up at more than 250 locations
right across the country workers tired
they say of the way they are being
treated the strike is disrupting Revenue
Canada immigration employment insurance
and passport offices Toria Israeli looks
at what's at stake in this Nationwide
strike and what the federal employees
want
work from home and they're prepared to
bring crucial services to a crawl to get
both we will stay out
for as long as
you put the Fair Deal on the table that
we deserve
tens of thousands of workers are on
strike Nationwide after negotiations hit
a wall inflation's at a 40-year high so
I'd say wages are definitely the number
one issue the union wants a 13 and a
half percent raise over three years for
members of the public servants Alliance
of Canada and a 22 and a half percent
wage hike for Canada Revenue Agency
employees the federal government is
prepared to offer nine percent over
three years to the various units
[Applause]
civil servants insist that's not enough
to deal with the rising cost of living
we will continue to work with the psac
to reach agreements that are fair and
competitive we cannot write a blank
check money isn't the only point of
contention workers are also fighting
against ottawa's return to the office
mandate we proved ourselves that we can
work efficiently and more productively
from home and
the fact that they're mandating us going
back to work two days a week just
doesn't make sense we should have the
option to choose if we want to risk our
health by going into the office every
day and we kind of got that choice taken
away from us essential services will
continue but there will be delays at the
CRA with the May 1st tax deadline around
the corner the strike will slow response
times at call centers and tax returns
filed on paper I get a return every year
and I'm expecting this year and I'm
going to have to wait for it but the
longest weights will be at the passport
office most applications are now on hold
the federal government only recently
cleared last Summer's backlog and there
are fears of it happening again if
someone has a family vacation planned
it's not considered to be an essential
service I feel very terrible for them
the crowds on Parliament Hill are now
gone in order for workers to collect
their 75 strike pay they have to show up
on the picket line for at least four
hours daily Donna all right turia Israel
in Ottawa tonight this strike is a
political headache for the Trudeau
government there's a great deal of
pressure to reach some kind of deal or
order the employees back to work before
a prolonged strike really disrupts
services to Canadians David Akin is
looking at the politics of this strike
David
well Donna so far as his strike is
concerned the Trudeau government has no
friends on the opposition benches while
the NDP has been backing the Liberals on
other matters such as the budget this
time they're advocating for the Striking
workers
[Applause]
conservatives through barbs at the
government on behalf of Canadians
inconvenienced by loss of services and
ultimately fundamentally it's Canadians
who suffer and of some note the
conservatives are not criticizing the
Striking public sector workers after
eight years of this liberal government
public servants are also suffering
suffering with higher cost of living
higher inflation both opposition parties
were keeping their focus on the PM this
is in the hands of the incompetent
Justin Trudeau and his team and we
really hope that he resolves this strike
soon I put the blame on the government
for not
putting forward a contract that respects
the pressures of inflation as for the
government itself it believes virtue and
perhaps some political credit lies in
the middle path maintain essential
Services while putting out Frontline
ministers to talk up how reasonable the
government's offer is all while finding
a negotiated settlement we will continue
to support unions and collective
bargaining this is uh the first day of
Labor disruptions we continue to be very
optimistic we're going to be able to see
this resolve where it needs to at the
bargaining table
well David what about Back To Work
legislation is it on the table or could
it be
yet not at this point Mark Holland is
the government house leader and he'd be
responsible for steering any such
legislation through the House of Commons
the first priority is to is to negotiate
we believe that fair settlement is
possible we believe the Fair Deal is on
the table and we believe it's essential
for that process to continue uh and so
we're going to stay right in the moment
and not engage in speculation of where
this might go but if the Federal
government ever did want to force the
strikers back to work it would not be
quick because of the rules around
parliamentary procedure it would be the
middle of next week at the earliest
before any legislation even if it were
contemplated could be debated and almost
certainly the NDP would engage in
probably days of filibustering and then
it would have to clear the Senate and
since all Senators right now are either
conservative or independent of the
liberal government there's no guarantee
the Senate would agree to quit Back To
Work legislation all of which is to say
this government is betting big on ending
this at the bargaining table and not in
the House of Commons Donna all right
we'll keep watching David Aiken and
Ottawa thanks The Washington Post is
reporting that according to leaked
documents prime minister Justin Trudeau
has privately told NATO officials Canada
will never meet its NATO defense
spending targets that Revelation was
contained in a leaked Secret Pentagon
assessment obtained by The Washington
Post Global News has been unable to
verify it our Ottawa bureau chief
Mercedes Stevenson is with me Mercedes
Canada hasn't met the two percent of GDP
Target for NATO funding for more than I
think 20 years but to say we'll never
meet it is that just widely accepted now
well and Donna it's remarkable because
it's a departure from the government's
public stance on this and I thought back
to when President Joe Biden was here and
I checked the press release to make sure
I wasn't imagining this sure enough in
there there is a reference to Canada and
the United States taking the whales
pledge seriously that is the pledge to
spend two percent as poor NATO's
requirements and yet what we're hearing
now is that the Prime Minister may be
seeing something very different behind
closed doors he was asked whether or not
he told NATO Canada will not get to two
percent earlier today this is what he
said
I continued to say and will always say
that Canada is a reliable partner to
Nato at reliable partner around the
world and with our military Investments
with the support we give to Canadians we
will continue to be doing that
Donna a reliable partner is not yes we
will get to two percent and
interestingly when I spoke to senior
government sources there was no sense to
me that they were striving for that
they're citing current defense
investments in things like planes and
ships but experts say that that's the
absolute minimum required for Canada to
be able to maintain its sovereignty so
this goes into a long list of questions
for the government about how much
they're actually willing to spend on
defense all right Mercedes Stevenson in
Ottawa thanks
it is spring but in parts of the
Southern prairies you'd never know it a
snowfall warning is in effect for
Southeastern Saskatchewan and into parts
of Manitoba several highways are closed
because of poor conditions Regina could
get up to 20 centimeters of snow over
the next two days Connor O'Donovan is
there in the snow tonight Connor
thanks Donna what we're experiencing
here in Saskatchewan today I would call
maybe third or fourth winter it is hard
to keep up when this is still happening
in late April one thing though is
certain the people of the Prairies know
how to take this weather in stride
[Music]
say a Colorado low is to blame for the
storm which is affecting nearly all of
Southern Saskatchewan areas in the
Southeast around Esteban and Weyburn
could see as many as 40 centimeters of
heavy wet snow all blown around by 80
kilometer an hour winds it's a
precipitation packed system that
originated in the area around Colorado
and it is moved to the north and it is
wrapping around wave after wave of heavy
snow across the area while the storm has
highways across the southeast closed
many here seem unfazed and ready to
manage the mess we always we always try
and stay prepared for these late spring
snowstorms so we haven't really started
transitioning any of our equipment over
in fact one Regina resident is so used
to the snow she's written a song about
it eager to do the shovel Shuffle as she
calls it at least one more time
everybody does it a different way has a
different rhythm a different
choreography to it so I thought it would
just be a good thing also to have a song
to help people go through that so long
winter that we have here in Saskatchewan
now the heaviest snow is expected today
but the storm not expected to taper off
until sometime Thursday after that these
Springtime double-digit highs not
expected to return until the end of next
week but after that hopefully we can
finally put those shovels away for good
Donna and look forward to flowers Connor
O'Donovan and Regina thanks
it's now projected India with more than
1.4 billion people will overtake China
as the world's most populous country by
the middle of this year there are now
more than 8 billion people on the planet
Canada is growing at a record Pace too
the population went up by 1 million
people in 2022 to close to 40 million
that's fueled by immigration in India
it's the birth rate that's driving up
the numbers the U.N population fund says
44 percent of women in the world are
unable to exercise bodily autonomy Mike
durlay looks at the numbers and the
trends
for every man or woman health care
worker pratima Kumari convinces to get
sterilized she makes 500 rupees roughly
eight dollars yet in the northern Indian
city of kishanganj which has the highest
fertility rate in the country it's a
losing battle
most of the people here are illiterate
she says they don't understand family
planning a health worker explains it to
them than I do and then my supervisor
does only then do they understand so
it's a huge concern there is the sense
that the population is just
two
two leads of all those people
for decades India has made a targeted
and multi-dimensional effort to reduce
population growth with incentives for
families to limit the number of children
to two
and in cities like kishangan to side
it's had an effect
as World fertility rates have declined
since 1950 so too of India and China's
to 2 and 1.19 births per woman
respectively China's rate is lower than
Canada's and is now amongst the lowest
in the world in large part due to the
one child policy it abandoned in 2016.
as a result India's population has
increased 300 percent since 1950. far
more than China or Canada for that
matter and the UN forecast shows how
China's population will actually
decrease beginning next year and that
growing Gap would be much narrower
experts say if Indian men took equal
responsibility for Family Planning the
really concerning statistic now around
sterilization is that only 0.3 percent
of all sterilizations that take place in
the country are for men the vast
majority of sterilizations are for women
India's population growth is certainly
slowing down but it will be decades
before it hits its peak microwave Global
News Toronto
and people in India are struggling to
stay cool this week as a grueling Heat
Wave hangs over parts of the country
more than a dozen people have died
temperatures have been hovering around
40 degrees since last week some places
have hit 44 degrees well above the
seasonal average India is one of the
country's most vulnerable to heat and
climate scientists predict heat waves
there will continue to arrive earlier
stay longer and become more frequent in
Sudan a new 24-hour ceasefire between
rival military factions appears to have
collapsed minutes after it went into
effect the humanitarian situation in
that country is growing increasingly
dire
grows over the capital city of
khartoumas fighting entered its fifth
straight day many hospitals have been
forced to close the few that are still
open or running out of medical supplies
food and water and there are concerns
the conflict could draw in neighboring
countries and destabilize the region
there is real Danger
that the escalation of hostilities in
Sudan could implicate external Regional
and international actors and degenerate
into a security and humanitarian crisis
on a disastrous scale
people in Khartoum have started to flee
and foreign governments are making plans
to move their citizens to safety nearly
300 people have died in the fighting as
the country's two powerful generals
battle for control
Canada hit with a salmonella outbreak
coming up why snakes and rodents are
being blamed plus sky-high solidarity
the French climber making a lofty
statement
[Music]
snakes and rodents are being blamed for
a salmonella outbreak in this country
that spans at least eight provinces the
public health agency of Canada says at
least one person has died Catherine Ward
explains what's driving the outbreak and
who is most vulnerable
we focused on respiratory viruses for a
good reason over the past two or three
years but it's important to remember the
risks of undercooked meat the risks that
are carried by contacting animals in in
various ways salmonella is often linked
to improperly cooked meat but there is
also a concern when it comes to animals
according to experts with health Canada
reptiles and and rodents can carry
salmonella naturally in their intestines
and they they don't appear to be sick at
all and then when pet owners touch them
or their environment or their food they
can unknowingly become infected with
salmonella the public health agency is
now leading an investigation because of
a recent spike in cases it'll cause an
infection usually in your
gastrointestinal tract causing pain in
the stomach abdominal pain diarrhea and
the like salmonella can then spread to
the blood cause of bacteremia that can
then spread to all organs 45 people
became sick with salmonella between
February 2022 and March 2023 with cases
stretching right across the country nine
people have been hospitalized and one
person has died nine of 45 of the cases
include children under five years of age
in addition others who are at risk
include pregnant people and seniors
health Canada urges families daycare
centers and schools to think twice about
allowing reptiles in places where there
could be young kids doctors say you can
protect yourself by washing your hands
cleaning surfaces often storing and
preparing Frozen rodents separately from
human food and watching kids closely you
raise your pet up to your face and you
kiss the pit that's not a good idea if
you're going to be handling any of these
pets please make sure to do so in a
sanitary way as you can wear gloves if
possible Catherine board Global News
Toronto
deadly disaster still ahead why patients
climbed out windows to escape a hospital
fire
[Music]
in France anger over president Emmanuel
macron's controversial pension reforms
reached New Heights today this
60-year-old free climber known as the
French Spider-Man scaled a 150 meter
high Skyscraper with just his hands as
climbing shoes and no harness he says he
did it to tell president Matt Krall to
come back down to earth and overturn the
new law raising the retirement age in
France from 62 to 64 years old in China
a fire at a hospital has killed at least
29 people most of them were critically
ill patients
smoke machine billowing out of the
windows at the Beijing Hospital on
Tuesday some people tried to escape by
climbing out the windows and sliding
down bed sheets some even balancing on
external air conditioning units initial
reports suggest the fire was started by
welding sparks a dozen people have been
detained by the police for questioning
including the hospital's director the
fire is one of the deadliest in China's
capital in at least two decades a group
of fishermen have been rescued from a
remote island off Western Australia
where they survived for six days without
food or water 11 Indonesian men were
aboard two fishing boats when they were
caught in a tropical Cyclone only one
fisherman from the second boat survived
spending 30 hours in the water before he
was washed ashore and was able to join
the others the group was rescued by air
on Monday they were taken to a hospital
on the mainland for treatment
they found what they weren't even
looking for we hear from the scientists
who discovered a pristine coral reef
[Music]
finding something you were actually
looking for is great finding something
you didn't think even existed is
exhilarating that's how scientists who
were mapping the ocean floor near the
Galapagos Islands are feeling they came
across a pristine previously unknown
coral reef believed to be several
thousand years old our Mike Armstrong
caught up with them to learn more about
what they found and what it means
sort of discovery that left scientists
wondering if what they were seeing was
even real the team's been working from
the research vessel Atlantis and Diving
to the ocean floor in a small submarine
called Alvin
they found earlier this week left the
scientists in Alvin cheering a healthy
coral reef teeming with life where they
absolutely didn't expect to find one we
were just gushing we were like it was
incredible we were able to reach The two
scientists who made the discovery
they're still at Sea on the Atlantis so
the connection was spotty but it was
strong enough for their exhilaration at
that moment to come through we are so
excited at seeing this it's us too and a
pilot and we are losing it the mission
was to map and Sample the ocean floor of
the Galapagos Marine reserve it's work
scientists have been doing for 20 years
now the Region's reefs were almost
completely wiped out by a period of
ocean warming in the 1980s this new
discovery was deeper about 600 meters
down which is likely why it survived
those reefs which literally could be you
know hundreds thousands of years of
growth yeah they're completely pristine
now global warming is decimating shallow
reefs around the world more than 90 of
the Great Barrier Reef off Australia has
been hit by Coral bleaching but this new
reef is undisturbed and protected
scientists Say by monitoring it in the
years ahead they'll be able to evaluate
the impact of the climate crisis they'll
also be able to take core samples and
look back in time the light little time
machine the like ocean time machines so
depending on when they lived and died
these fossils will tell you what was
going on in the ocean then
coral reefs cover only about one percent
of the ocean but about a quarter of all
marine life lives off of them finding
this Reef the scientists say is a good
argument for protecting more of the
ocean
Mike I'm from Global News Montreal
amazing stuff that is global national
for this Wednesday I'm Donna Friesen
tonight's your Canada is Abraham Lake in
Clearwater County Alberta we'd love to
see your Canada please email it to
viewers at globalnational.com and thanks
for watching hope to see you here again
tomorrow bye-bye
[Music]